تطورات واحداث متسارعه استشهد قضيه تويتر
وال الماسك اللي من اول يوم استحفظ فيه
على تويتر ما يضيع وقت ابدا فماسك ترب عرض
الحائط كل الشكوى والانتقادات لطالته بسبب
قراره فرض رسوم 8$ للحفاظ على العلامه
الزرقاء للحسابات الموثقه فالقرار دخل حيز
التنفيذ في التحديث الجديد لنظام ايوس
باجهزه ابل واعلن عن بدء الاشتراك بالميزه
وببدا التنفيذ في الولايات المتحده وكندا
واستراليا ونيوزيلندا والمملكه المتحده
بمجرد ما تكتب الان في مجال التطبيقات
تويتر وتدخل على التطبيق راح تشوف الرساله
اللي شايفينها امامكم الان وفيها كاتب
تويتر عن ميزات الاشتراك في تويتر بلو
مقابل ثمانيه دولارات شهريا واللي بتتضمن
تقليل عدد الاعلانات والقدره على نشر
مقاطع فيديو بمده اطول من السابق ومحتوى
اكثر انتقائيه ما يتضمن حمايه المستخدم من
الاسلام والبط
وطبعا ماسكه عبر السيل من التغريدات اكد
على تمسك بالقرار لو ايش ما صار وذكر
ميزات العلامه الزرقاء بدايه من التزام
تويتر بالاشراف على المحتوى من دون اي
تغيير وكمان حصول صانعي المحتوى على مدخول
مادي من خلال محتواهم اللي بينشروه مرورا
باضافه ميزه النص الطويل في التغريدات
والابتعاد عن اللجوء لخاصيه النودز
وتصويرها ووضعها في التغريده وهو الامر
اللي وصفوا ماسك بالسخيفه وانتهاء بمقاطع
الفيديو اللي يمكن تحميل مده اطول منها
وبدقه اعلى الى مثلا الطولها بيصير مثلا
42 دقيقه بدقيقه 1000 بالاضافه الى تحسين
عمليات البحث اللي وصفها انها بتذكره
بالطرق القديمه وعد بتحسينها على الثور
وعلى فكره هذا مو القرار الوحيد اللي طبق
وماسك ودخل تويتر ودخلته وتويتر في دوامه
كبيره ففي كمان قرار الشركات الكبيره
المعلنه في تويتر عن انسحابهم للمنصه
ومقاطعتها بالاضافه الى تسريحه الموظفين
من الخدمه ففعلا ماسك صرف نصف موظفي شركه
تويتر يعني 3700 موظف والى المسك بررت
تنفيذ القرار بانه حط كل اللوم على انخفاض
الايرادات الهائل بسبب الضغوط والسحاب
الشركات المعلنه من تويتر وقال انه ما
عنده خيار ثاني لان الشركه جلسه تخسر 4
مليون دولار في اليوم واضاف ماسك انه صرف
لي الموظفين اللي تم تسريحهم تعويض ثلاثه
اشهر وهو زياده 50% عن القانون يعني هو
عاطيهم حقهم وزياده بحسب رايه طبعا عمليات
الفصل الجماعي اللي صارت خلت احد مؤسسي
تويتر واللي هو جاك دور سيخرج عن صمته
ويحط اللون على نفسه في اللي جاي بيصير
وقال ان هو المسؤول عن هذا الشيء لانه هو
كبر تويتر بسرعه كبيره واعتذر للناس واكد
انهم اقوياء ومارينيين وراح يلاقوا طريقه
يخرجوا فيها من صعوبه الموقف ودور سيمو
الوحيد اللي علق فالمفوض السامي للامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان والكرتون ارسل
رساله مفتوحه لمسك فيها دروس لحمايه حريه
التعبير ووصف لجالس بيصير في تويتر ببدايه
غير مشجعه وحط مجموعه من المبادئ اللي
لازم توتير يلتزم فيها مثل حريه التعبير
والشفافيه والخصوصيه ورفض خطاب الكراهيه
والتميز
وطبعا موظفين تويتر المفصولين مسكتوا عن
اللي صار وفي معلومات كشفت عنها شبكه فوكس
نيوز الامريكيه وقالت فيها ان الموظفين
راح يرفعوا الدعوه قضائيه ضد ماسك لانه
اللي صار هو تجاوز للقانون الفيدرالي لانه
ماسك او تويتر ما بعرف لهم اشعار قبل
المده القانونيه اللازمه ومع ازمه
الموظفين زي ما ذكرت تويتر او زي ما انا
ذكرت سابقا في بدايه حديث اليوم تويتر
بواجه حملات مقاطعه كبيره من الشركات ويوم
عن يوم بيزيد عددها فمن بعد جانر الموتوس
اللي وقفت اعلانات السابقه في تويتر في
شركات كثيره جديده اعلنت ايقاف الاعلانات
مؤقتا كمان منها بنقول فايز في اودي في
ديزني في مازدا في كوكاكولا وغيره كمان
ايضا